[Música]
asciende al menos 40 la cifra de muertos
por los deslaves en el estado de Sao
Paulo en Brasil los desaparecidos se
cuentan por decenas mientras cientos de
rescatistas buscan por supervivientes en
una tragedia que enluta la celebraciones
del carnaval
ya está en Chile el equipo italiano de
expertos que va a investigar los
incendios que han causado estragos en el
país y se han cobrado la vida de 25
personas así como han calcinado más de
400.000 hectáreas el gobierno estima que
el 25% de las conflagraciones son
intencionales Tenemos reporte desde
Santiago
hay un tercer caso en el mundo que ha
conseguido curarse del VIH se lo conoce
como el paciente de dusseldorf y superó
el virus gracias a un trasplante de
células madre para tratar una leucemia
Cómo funcionan esas terapias tenemos
análisis
[Música]
nueva emisión informativa aquí en la
pantalla de Francia 24 Estas son las
noticias más destacadas del continente
americano Mi nombre es Juan pupiales las
autoridades del estado de Sao Paulo en
Brasil reportan al menos 40 muertos y
más de 300 damnificados tras un fin de
semana de lluvias récord el gobierno
Estatal decretó la calamidad pública y
anunció la liberación de uno coma tres
millones de dólares de ayuda para las
tareas de rescate Mientras tanto el
presidente Luis Ignacio urulada Silva
visitó la región y prometió paliar los
daños
Caos y destrucción tras una fuerte
jornada de lluvias récord que afectó el
norte del estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil
en especial en la ciudad de Sao
Sebastián durante el fin de semana de
carnaval provocando inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra el gobierno de
Sao Paulo decretó el estado de calamidad
pública por 180 días en las cinco
ciudades más afectadas y el presidente
Lula da Silva prometió una acción o
coordinada
puedo garantizar que mis ministros y el
gobernador están dispuestos a dialogar
para que podamos trabajar conjuntamente
para reparar de manera efectiva los
daños que la lluvia ha ocasionado aquí
en Sao Sebastián
las lluvias acumularon unos 600
milímetros superando el nivel que se
esperaba para todo el mes de febrero en
medio del carnaval además de los cientos
de personas que se vieron obligadas a
evacuar sus hogares muchos viajeros que
decidieron pasar sus vacaciones en la
región también tuvieron que evacuar
desastre por el que el gobierno como
local haya anunciado el desembolso de
alrededor de un millón y medio de
dólares para las tareas de rescate y
reconstrucción
ayer no pudimos sacar nuestro auto Así
que está dañado y casi perdemos otras
cosas de dentro de casa
la situación está crítica sólo tenemos
una salida para ir hacia Sao Paulo está
todo inundado
estamos medio aislados aquí con ráfagas
de viento que marcaron hasta 55
kilómetros por hora el Instituto
Nacional de meteorología reportó que las
lluvias continuaran en la zona costera
del estado en los próximos días Lo que
podría agravar la situación las
autoridades en México reportaron que ya
son 17 los muertos por el accidente de
un bus en el que se transportaban 45
pasajeros entre ellos migrantes
provenientes de Colombia Venezuela y
varios países de América Central el
siniestro ocurrió cuando el conductor
del vehículo perdió el control mientras
transitaba por la autopista
Oaxaca
Lamentablemente
viajaban 45 personas son habitantes de
origen extranjero Y todos al parecer sin
documentos de Colombia de Venezuela de
Centroamérica como adelantábamos en
titulares este lunes llegó a Chile un
equipo de expertos de Italia que va a
investigar los incendios que afectado al
país y que en las últimas dos semanas
dejan 25 muertos y más de 400.000
hectáreas calcinadas de acuerdo con
estimaciones del propio gobierno el 25%
de esos focos fueron intencionados
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal Patricia Luna en Santiago
quien nos entregó más detalles sobre
estas cifras según un estudio de la
corporación nacional forestal uno de los
organismos que está en el terreno
combatiendo los incendios de 650
incendios y bien investigados un 25,1%
tendrían una intencionalidad evaluando
aspectos técnicos haciendo una
investigación sobre el origen de estos
incendios la ministra del interior
Carolina toja afirmó en su último
balance que sabemos que hay
intencionalidad en los incendios y
también que el 99,8% de estos incendios
tienen una causa humana pero que también
hay otros factores como negligencia o
Estados Temerarios en este respecto
ministra también señaló que existen en
el país 39 detenidos por esta causa la
mayoría de ellos son por negligencias o
por instruir en la labor de extinción de
las brigadas algo que también se ha
producido de forma aislada en algunas
ocasiones Y que solo una pequeña minoría
sería asociada a esta intencionalidad
una esperanzadora noticia fue publicada
por la revista especializada en nature
hablamos de un estudio sobre la tercera
persona jurada del VIH reconocido como
el paciente de düsseldorf una ciudad
alemana es un individuo cuya identidad
se mantiene en secreto y que logró
erradicar cualquier rastro del virus
después de un trasplante de células
madre para tratar una leucemia
previamente hablamos con el doctor Erick
Delgado Zárate magíster en enfermedades
infecciosas y VIH especializan
epidemiología y salud pública quien
explicó Cuál es el alcance de este tipo
de tratamientos
realmente son pacientes que tienen
enfermedades
asociadas al VIH donde lo que se busca
es a través de El trasplante de médula
ósea poder generar la capacidad de que
en un momento dado
se genere la presencia de mutaciones en
el momento en que se hace la donación de
la médula y con eso lograr la prevenir
la replicación del virus del VIH sin
embargo es muy importante explicar que
este tipo de terapias no se pueden
llevar a gran escala son terapias
altamente costosas Pero además de eso
requieren de muchos estudios y además de
eso no todos los pacientes son
candidatos a este tipo de terapias
Generalmente lo que hemos visto con el
primer paciente que es lo conocemos como
el paciente Berlín El segundo paciente
que lo conocemos como el paciente
Londres es que se ha logrado la
implementación o el el lograr una
mutación que lleva finalmente a que los
pacientes finalmente presenten este tipo
de cura pero no es una terapia aplicable
a toda la población o a más de los 37
millones de personas que habitan en el
planeta después de de en este momento
con diagnóstico de VIH
volvemos a Brasil pero esta vez para
hablar del carnaval de Río de Janeiro
que la noche del lunes celebró su última
jornada de desfiles es la última ocasión
para ver en acción algunas de las dos
escuelas con sus 3000 integrantes en
acción unos 70.000 espectadores pueden
disfrutar de este espectáculo a lo largo
de los 700 metros del sambódromo Y en
este año ya sin restricciones por la
pandemia de covid-19 la escuela ganadora
la vamos a conocer este miércoles fuera
de Brasil en Colombia y Bolivia también
son días de mucha fiesta nuestro
compañero Max Pérez Gallardo nos lleva
por este recorrido
[Música]
la región del color febrero mes de
carnavales para América Latina celebra
la diversidad que nutre a los pueblos
este año las complejidades políticas de
la región también se asoman en la fiesta
y muchos artistas están aprovechando el
espacio de los carnavales para
expresarse políticamente en Brasil las
tensiones originadas por el proceso
electoral que el país vivió
recientemente han salido a flote en esta
edición
es una doble alegría porque somos libres
de nuevo con toda la libertad de
expresión y peleando por nuestros
derechos para que todos seamos iguales
no hay diferencias entre colores de piel
creo que el carnaval va a ser una
celebración de esta conquista
democrática el carnaval es felicidad
Colombia es el hogar de otro festival
icónico de la región el carnaval de
Barranquilla representa un homenaje a la
identidad del país es una mezcla de
tradiciones prehispánicas y de la
colonia que resulta en una celebración
al mestizaje latinoamericano el carnaval
del Barranquilla la fiesta cultural más
importante por su diversidad por la
inclusión por la variedad producto de la
combinación de triernias que se da en
tierras bolivianas el festival de oruro
es sinónimo de remembranza a los
orígenes del país considerado como
patrimonio oral e intangible de la
humanidad por la UNESCO el festival
despliega una mezcla entre dioses
andinos e iconografía cristiana río
oruro Barranquilla tres palabras
sinónimo de una explosión de colorido
mezcla de razas y de patrimonio cultural
que cada año atraen decenas de miles de
turistas
así despedimos esta emisión informativa
la información continua en esta
pantallita y también en nuestro sitio
web France 24.com
[Música]